مشاهده مرحبا بكم في قناه الجزيره اعلانات
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انا انظمه لي الدفاع
الجوي احبطت هجوما بطائره مسيره اوكرانيه
على قاعده عسكريه في مقاطعه السرتون جنوب
الشرقيه العاصمه وقالت الوزاره انها ثلاثه
جنود قتلوا جراء سقوط الطائره المصريه
وانه يفضل ان تكون في الامم المتحده مع
الامم انطونيلش كماسيتا محتمله
ورفض الكرملين امكانيه اجراء المفاوضات في
الامم المتحده بشروط اوكرانيا من ناحيته
جددها وزير الخارجيه الروسيه
مطالب بلاده بنزع السلاح والتخلصي من
وصفهم بالنازيين
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع التايوانيه ان احدى
وسبعين طائره صينيه ما بين مقاتله ومسيره
اخترقت منطقه تحديث الان
على متحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي
جميع الاجراءات اللازمه للدفاع عن سياده
البلاد وسلامه اراضيها
قناه الاتحاد التونسي للشغل انه بدا
مشاورات من اجل بلوره تصور لمبادره مع
منظمات وقوه المجتمع المدني لانقاذ البلاد
اضاف الامين العام للاتحاد نور الدين
الطموبينه لو كانت هناك رجاجه عقل سياسي
وحينكه لدى اصحاب القرار لكان رئيس الصعيد
قتل رساله الشعب من خلال نسب العزوف عن
المشاركه في الانتخابات التشريعيه الاخيره
لجهه قال الرئيس هو التنسيق الصعيد ان
العمليه التي غبيه ستتواصل وان الشعب
سيقول كلمته في الانتخابات
ومحاوله اسقاط الدوله على حديث تعبيره
ارتفع عدده ضحايا العاصفه الثلجيه في
الولايات المتحده الى الثمانيه واربعين
قتيلا بعد اعلان ولايه نيويورك ارتفاع عدد
الضحايا في منطقه بافلوب بالولايات
بالولايات الى 25 قتيلا وادت العاصفه الى
الغاء 15000 رحله جويه خلال الايام
الاخيره وتسببت في انقطاع التيار
الكهربائي عن اكثر من مليون شخص واغلاق
اعاده كبير من الطرق
شكرا لكم اينما كنتم في امل